[Music]  madman actress Christina Hendricks is in  the news yeah as you probably if she is  good lord  as you've where am i again as you've  probably heard somebody hacked her  cellphone and released a topless photo  Hendricks supposedly took of herself  well the story's all over the internet  everyone's talking about it it's amazing  how many people are discussing this  issue even President Obama weighed in  about the hacking of Christina Hendricks  phone just a few hours ago I think we  can all agree this is a good day for  America today we are reminded that as a  nation there's nothing we can't do and  we are truly blessed  [Applause]